[Music]  winner of the voice is  [Applause]  it was an epic night of firsts on  Tuesday season 14 finale of The Voice as  fifteen-year-old Brynn cartelli beat out  the competition to take home the top  prize ET was backstage with Brynn and  her coach Kelly Clarkson after the big  win but Blake called you Queen Kelly  Clarkson oh girl don't think I'm not  waiting yes oh yeah haven't checked my  phone but I'm gonna hold on to it yes  the Alicia and I was so funny at the end  we were like we love Brittany and it was  one of those things we were like  regardless like a female's walking out  of here a winner and it was it was  really Elysian eyes gold just to beat  the Cowboys so success how long does he  have to call you that I don't think I  don't I don't know if we put a I think  all next season I think I'm just kidding  I won't hit him go say it can't go fall  through  [Music]  [Applause]